oh i don't give a sh
well from bloody good time to straight
up bloody machine gun kelly displaying
some bizarre behavior at his concert
after party i guess you could say mgk
really tapped into his inner rock star
okay i'm really sorry but the only words
leaving my mouth for the rest of the day
is that we're at the garden tonight
mgk performed to a sold-out crowd at his
msg concert at madison square gardens in
new york on tuesday mgk is taking over
msg tomorrow right
how are you feeling about
a blessing huh yeah yeah he seemed
grounded and grateful when e.t spoke to
him just one day before so no one was
expecting this the rapper smashing a
champagne glass over his head he
captioned the video in his ig story and
this is when things turned yeah and get
this mgk keeps on performing as blood
streams down his face
before the after party mgk pulled out
all the stops giving concert goers tons
of punk rock energy on stage and the
best part he flew in on a pink
helicopter
[Music]
we can't say we're completely shocked by
the mainstream sellout rapper's behavior
toward the end of his set concert goers
watched as mgk flew into a rage storming
off stage towards a crew member who
appeared to be working sound though it's
still unclear what exactly set him off i
mean it's been an interesting two years
of
the
fame taking on a different
life than i could have imagined it doing
the concert and its explosive aftermath
come just after the release of kelly's
new documentary life in pink my life
wasn't always like this the movie takes
a look at mgk's battle with life's
demons with a shocking reveal he nearly
took his own life in 2020. that's like
something i'm not proud of it wasn't my
choice to have that in a documentary i
think that some of those things like
in speaking on the truth for the last
two years
that is one of them and i didn't also
want to
hide anything i was trying to level
myself and ground myself and be
like make a choice to become a a better
father and a
a good partner to
my lady
[Music]
mgk was on the phone with his fiance
megan fox during his suicide attempt the
actress tells us how they are growing
and healing since those dark days we've
done every form of therapy that exists
we've found a therapist that really
works for us couples and individually
and
it's definitely a process it's not an
easy one
[Music]